bienvenidos a casa de las américas café
el castor cibernético una emisión
producida por la sección en español del
dibujo público radio canadá
internacional difundimos en directo cada
viernes a las doce y cuarto por las
redes sociales en internet y esta
emisión también se encuentra disponible
en nuestro sitio
heresi net punto sea este programa es un
espacio dedicado a compartir sus
mensajes nuestro correo electrónico es
hablado
heresi net punto o sea hoy les acompañan
en los micrófonos pero no ahora chapman
pablo gómez barrios leonardo gimeno y
quienes salva rojo valencia también en
algunos instantes más les presentaremos
a nuestra invitada que se encuentra allá
en la ciudad de mexico
previamente decir es que en la versión
audio de este programa escucharemos
música de dana en the day out también
tendremos al dúo maliense amadou y
mariam con un arreglo del tema más de la
ddi y también escucharemos desde
colombia una canción del bogotano
esteban mateos williamson que se llama
en escena este man
y su canción será no te metas en mi
facebook así que lo que ustedes podrán
escuchar en la versión audio ahora
empezamos como es habitual con alguna
noticia que ustedes hayan destacado una
semana no sé leonardo quiere empezar
también las noticias que me destacan son
las del deporte y el hecho de el 'robo
del siglo' le dicen por ahí hemos
discutido con pablo de acuerdo pero
bueno como quedó fuera barcelona como
estuvo así de cara a fuera el real
madrid y como el fútbol ya no da ninguna
seguridad con una idea leonardo sería de
preguntarles a nuestros amigos que nos
están escuchando allá que nos siguen en
el facebook live qué piensan ellos a ver
si siguen la diferencia ese solo entre
tú y yo
entre ustedes dos dependiendo el grupo
de interés que responda a esa pregunta
por ejemplo los británicos decían que
fue muy bien dado ese penal porque el
árbitro escrita
en fin después de la rivalidad
barcelona-real madrid los periódicos de
barcelona
también se nota esa rivalidad lo que vi
interesante fue una encuesta en
argentina que se hizo entre la gente
diciendo bueno fue robado no fue robado
el gol no y yo creo que la respuesta fue
bastante elevada diciendo que sí que se
habían robado a ese partido no yo no
tengo ningún interés a ello porque había
un colombiano que últimamente jugaba al
madrid e intereses por ejemplo la gente
de costa rica no quiere al real madrid
porque el arquero es costarricense
a la juve porque hay dos jugadores
argentinos en la juve o sea uno si hay
pero el tema es que se repita y que en
medios entre comillas que no tienen nada
que ver digan que esté teniendo la
posibilidad de utilizar el bar que es
este método para salvar utilizado no no
en ese partido podrían haberlos
perfectamente ido a ver revisar pero eso
pone en duda también la fiabilidad del
árbitro entonces no se utilizó y bueno
pasó diferencia del hockey aquí como se
transmite directamente en la televisión
cuando hay una duda se para el partido y
los árbitros están visión visualizan esa
jugada en cámara lenta y ahí mismo se
decide si hubo gol o no hubo gol o si
hubo infracción no no eso resuelve el
progreso caso del problema y para eso
estaría el bar supuestamente y si no que
siga como se hace en
en el fútbol americano que cada equipo
tiene por tiempo dos posibilidades de
utilizar la revisión de vídeo con el
tenis como el tenis exacto entonces eso
por lo menos aliviaría un poco la
presión y si se gastó las dos
posibilidades de gasto es más fácil de
aceptar entonces el veredicto es que
tienes como tema de esta semana bueno
digamos que la noticia que llamó mi
atención es este niño que fue suspendido
de la escuela en porque en aquí en que
ve que en una escuela de en región en la
región de laurent y da porque se
presentó con una camiseta del barça no
del real madrid pero de una camiseta del
barça a su escuela y
el director el profesor lo mandó a ver
el director y el director le dijo que se
cambiara la camiseta o que estaba
suspendido
y el muchacho dijo bueno yo me voy la
razón por la cual el chico tenía esa
camiseta es porque este viernes era el
día nacional de la camiseta así se llama
acá que habían decretado en vancouver
unas madres de familia para en apoyo a
las víctimas de la tragedia que hubo en
humboldt saskatchewan en la que
perdieron la vida 15 jóvenes entre 17 y
21 años miembros del equipo de hockey de
ese pueblo entonces hubo una reacción
nacional e incluso parlamentarios del
partido conservador en ottawa llegaron y
vistieron camisetas de hockey que estuve
días en distintas ciudades en vancouver
y en distintos lugares gentes que tenían
y que vestían camisetas de deportes no
forzosamente de hockey pero
camisetas deportivas pero al parecer
como que el director de la escuela y el
portavoz de la comisión escolar no
estaba muy al tanto sobre ese tema y
decidieron suspender al chico iloílo y
lo mandaron de regreso a su casa ahora
después se dieron cuenta que
efectivamente era una campaña de
solidaridad con las víctimas de la
tragedia de humboldt entonces dijeron
que para salir del paso que iban a
organizar con los chicos de la escuela
una forma de solidarizarse con estas
víctimas pero la realidad fue que los
suspendieron porque no estaban ellos al
tanto de esta campaña nacional creo y el
chico se negó a quitarse la camiseta
claro por menos no era una camiseta de
hockey de un equipo que nadie conocía
que eso era lo que decían las
autoridades que si al menos hubiera sido
una camiseta de hockey de un del equipo
de los broncos que se llama se llama así
el equipo de hockey de handball que
bueno si hubiera sido una
de buena fe pero que él está tenía una
camiseta del barça y entonces que eso no
era tolerable
solo para agregar un poquito no son 15
los muertos sino ya son 16 yo también
una chica que era la fisioterapeuta creo
del equipo una joven también que no
estaba pues generado virtual en estado
crítico y también falleció ahora yo voy
a destacar sólo algo que hice también
esta semana el rufo que se me llamó
muchísimo la atención que es una
simulación que hizo estadísticas canadá
mira la gran agencia está federal que es
con quique es pues recopila datos sobre
la inmigración en el país el editor de
net claro hicieron una simulación de 100
años y la pregunta que ellos hicieron es
qué pasaría si canadá no cierra las
puertas directamente a los inmigrantes
entonces hicieron una simulación a
partir del año 2006 que eran las
estadísticas del 2006 hasta es 22 mil
106 y es algo que es impresionante van
de 20 años en 20 años de aquí a 20 años
que es canadá pues en 20 años y se
reservaron las puertas hay un
crecimiento
acción canadiense pero más leve de lo
que se espera y los 40 y los 80 hasta
llegar a los 100 años que pasa y se
dieron cuenta según las cifras que en el
2000 106 canadá ya hubiera perdido un
tercio de su población es bastante
impresionante ese estudio que hicieron y
es bueno ahí hablan un poco de otros
temas hicieron otros análisis entonces
creo que valdría la pena también de
echarle una miradita a eso de
estadísticas canadá bien ahora vamos a
presentarles a nuestra invitada y está
en mexico se trata de la profesora leona
rosales mendoza ella enseña en la
universidad pedagógica nacional y
trabaja en el área de la diversidad y la
interculturalidad
leonard bienvenida a radio canadá
internacional muchas gracias
gracias por la invitación con nosotros
usted tiene alguna noticia que le haya
llamado atención alguna algo fuera de lo
común allí en méxico o en otro lugar del
mundo
bueno hay muchas noticias ahora en esta
etapa que estamos teniendo de elecciones
de campañas electorales hay un clima
político difícil digamos
y bueno pues esa es la gran noticia de
que en méxico el año 2012 usted estuvo
en montreal estuvo haciendo justamente
una instancia de investigación en la
universidad mcgill aquí en la ciudad de
montreal cuéntenos de qué se trataba y
cuerda el objetivo así es en el año 2012
asistí a la universidad ma jin a la
escuela de trabajo social con la doctora
del handling para realizar una
investigación sobre el tema de la
migración los derechos humanos y la
interculturalidad
específicamente la investigación se
llevó a cabo en la región de sangre milk
aunque ve y yo buscaba concretamente a
trabajadores agrícolas temporales del
programa de trabajadores agrícolas
temporales méxico-canadá de la región de
yucatán de la península de yucatán
porque de la península de yucatán porque
es una región que hasta ahora ha sido
poco expulsora de migrantes en términos
generales hacia los eeuu pero también en
este programa concretamente de el del
petate
y realice investigación en los años
previos en la región de la península de
yucatán que comprende los estados de
yucatán quintana roo y campeche y
encontré que era alrededor de 100
hombres que acudían a esta zona de
quebec a trabajar la investigación se
centró básicamente en la temática como
mencionaba en la temática de los
derechos humanos de cómo estaba su
situación por allá de cuestiones
interculturales de prácticas
interculturales muy interesantes como
pueden ser por ejemplo la práctica que
llevan a cabo para pedir agua a los
chaqués en la milpa yucateca
y ahí me encontré en una cuestión muy
interesante y es que en yucatán
esto está práctica cultural requiere
hasta un espacio a un espacio practicado
dentro de la milpa porque se lleva a
cabo a través de un ritual en la región
de quebec bueno sucede una cosa muy
diferente yo les preguntaba a los
migrantes si era posible llevar a cabo
un ritual de esta naturaleza ya
de manera muy peculiar me desean o no
como como cree como crees eso no puede
suceder en quebec porque toda la
creencia está allá o sea toda la
creencia está en méxico eso quiere decir
que estas prácticas culturales son
posibles y hay una fuerte creencia en
que realmente los chaqués vendrán a
proporcionar agua y a dar como una buena
cosecha
qué es otra cosa porque está como todas
las formas como ellos le llaman
tecnologizadas hay como toda una serie
de sistemas de riego y otras de otras
prácticas distintas que se llevan a cabo
allá y que tienen que ver más con él con
el tema de la agricultura
a nivel tecnológico y cómo afecta a
estos trabajadores migrantes yucatecos
el hecho de tener la materialidad de la
naturaleza de la agua pero perder todos
esos esos referentes de una de una
cosmovisión
bueno justamente cuando realizaba
investigación en el año 2012 y después
aquí en en la península de yucatán
durante 2013 14-15 me daba cuenta de que
era una realidad muy diferente de la que
ellos vivían en sus comunidades méxico y
la que vivían en las regiones de quebec
cuando ellos iban a trabajar entonces
resulta que ellos entran como en un
estado de pase como en ola en la pausa
de su vida y de sus prácticas tanto
familiares como culturales cuando están
allá pero no no es para menos son muchos
meses los que pasan algunos de ellos en
mi canadá es decir a veces viven más
tiempo allá que en sus comunidades
rurales aquí en méxico y eso me llamó la
atención con una maestra estudiante de
doctorado de la universidad de montreal
linamar campos ella es
antes del programa de geografía humana
nos dimos a la tarea de plantear
investigar la migración desde otro y ese
otro lugar y ver qué pasaba con la
subjetividad de los de los trabajadores
agrícolas ella linamar campos trabaja
con hombres
japan ecos también en la región sur de
de méxico
y planteamos entonces qué pasaba con las
emociones
cuando empezamos a realizar entrevistas
sobre el tema de la de las emociones nos
dábamos cuenta que los trabajadores/as y
analizaban mucho lo que les
preguntábamos acerca de emociones porque
la tristeza la soledad la angustia la
preocupación inclusive sobre estados de
bienestar como es la alegría
empezamos a investigar algunos textos
que nos llevan la pauta para implementar
un método cualitativo distinto al
momento de realizar las entrevistas y
nos hallamos con una propuesta muy
interesante de doblas harper que que se
refiere a la foto en licitación esto es
la manera de utilizar la fotografía
dentro de la investigación para lograr
determinados objetivos de esa
investigación
para nosotras era interesante esta
aportación pero intentamos por otro lado
la diferencia fundamental entre la
propuesta nuestra que es algo así como
foto equina con foto de vocación
para harper la imagen en sí misma es un
dato la fotografía es un dato que
permite reconstruir o recrear espacios
en situaciones determinadas y para
nosotros la fotografía es utilizado como
forma como elemento para evocar las
emociones
entonces realizamos un ejercicio
interesante con los migrantes yucatecos
con los migrantes chiapanecos y también
con sus parejas
con sus esposas o concubinas y
encontramos que a través de la
presentación de determinadas fotografías
equivocábamos esas emociones de las que
nosotros estábamos que vienen no que
fueran más espontáneas que fueran menos
racionalizados y pues en esto estamos
ahora de momento hemos realizado ya el
trabajo con solapa nexos con yucatecos
los migrantes temporales con sus esposas
y en mi reciente visita a la región de
quebec a hacer dos semanas hicimos
también un ejercicio con trabajadores
agrícolas guatemaltecos en radio canadá
internacional estamos en conversación
con leona rosales mendoza profesora
universidad pedagógica nacional en
méxico y el estado como ustedes han
podido escuchar trabajando el tema de la
subjetividad y las emociones
esos espacios del subconsciente
consciente que son afectados por la
experiencia de ese trabajador migrante
alguna pregunta a compañeros bueno yo le
quería preguntar a leona si esas largas
ausencias como se manifiestan en sus
relaciones entre los trabajadores que
están acá y su familia que se quedan en
méxico
bueno ese es bastante difícil para
trabajadores para sus familias estar
separados por por muchos meses pueden
ser cuatro meses ocho meses hasta diez y
ellos mantienen una comunicación
constante a través de los teléfonos
celulares a través de videoconferencias
y eso no les permite sentirse cerca les
permiten sentir que esas emociones
pueden ser negociadas en la distancia
entonces creo que las nuevas tecnologías
se han traído como una nueva dinámica a
estas familias cosa que no ocurría que
no sucedía
hace algunos años
si leona yo tendría una pregunta no sé
si ésta tiene la respuesta pero me
pregunto cuáles son a lo mejor las
consecuencias de estos trabajadores que
vienen por tanto tiempo y no sólo una
vez hay trabajadores que vienen varias
veces durante varios años es que eso
causa problemas en las relaciones
familiares
bueno justamente hicimos esa revisión
comparativa entre lo que sucedía en
chiapas y lo que sucede en yucatán y
encontramos algunas diferencias
sustanciales
entre los water entre los chamanes
perdón hallamos más casos de
separaciones o de divorcios
cuestiones incluso de violencia de parte
del hombre hacia la mujer que entre los
yucatecos no firmó por contendientes
estamos explorando muchísimo más esta
cuestión pero el dato que tenemos por
ahí apunta a que tienen que ver un poco
con la cuestión de las prácticas
religiosas es decir en el sureste de
méxico han permeado muchísimo las
religiones cristianas distintas a la
católica y esto ha posibilitado como
otras otras prácticas como de mayor
respeto pero es complejo digamos el
término de este tema de la migración
porque por ejemplo en relación con esta
práctica de los chaqués que se
mencionaba hace unos momentos esta
práctica sólo he tomado a cabo por los
católicos
los aquellos
que están adscritos a otras religiones
cristianas ya no llevan a cabo esta
práctica cultural porque bueno sus
religiones se los impiden no se los
prohíbe entonces
bueno hay como muchas variables que se
pueden cruzar por ahí y que no queremos
llegar a una conclusión todavía pero en
la dinámica familiar son muy diferentes
en los contextos y en otros en los
contextos indígenas
que yo estudio mucho en la península de
yucatán hay mucha cohesión con este tema
de la migración con la cuestión de irse
hay mucha solidaridad en otros contextos
mestizos y puede que haya menos este
aspecto de considerar que la familia
debe mantenerse unida a pesar de todo y
si ella
en total algunos casos de separaciones y
divorcios y finalmente profesora leona
rosales mendoza este trabajo de
investigación sobre la migración de
trabajadores temporales a canadá tomando
en cuenta la historia de méxico por
ejemplo el tiempo de la que dan los
cristeros por ejemplo o la o la
urbanización del distrito federal que
atrae mano de obra desde todas las
regiones de méxico dentro de méxico se
ha estudiado está este impacto de los
movimientos económicos y sus
consecuencias en la subjetividad del de
kim migra
hay estudios que se han realizado claro
tenemos muchos estudiosos muy
renombrados y hay un seminario de
estudios méxico-estados unidos-canadá en
la universidad nacional autonoma de
mexico y co presidido por la doctora
sara lara y se ha llevado tres estudios
muchos es allí en la región de quebec en
varias regiones de méxico el tema de las
emociones ha sido un tema poco abordado
ese es un tema que sí ha sido estudiado
en otros contextos de las ciencias
sociales pero en la migración digamos es
recientes de algunos años para acá hay
estudios sobre la migración y las
emociones en poblaciones que se dirigen
a los estados unidos pero que tienen
características muy diferentes a las del
programa adores agrícolas temporales
porque unos son trabajadores con papeles
y otros son trabajadores sin papeles
entonces eso hace una gran gran
diferencia
bien muchas gracias profesora leona
rosales mendoza gracias por participar
en este programa de las américas en las
ondas de radio canadá internacional
hasta la próxima
bueno tras el breve paseo por por méxico
e interesante el tema de explorar
justamente cómo afecta no de la
subjetividad a persona lo que es
interesante es como las creencias frente
al agua gente los elementos naturales
está una especie de paréntesis o de o de
suspensión de la creencia y que los
dioses son sólo los en las actividades
son solamente locales y lo que es
interesante de lo que decía leona es
algo es un tema que no es muy
investigado me parece que es algo nuevo
tal vez es que nosotros sí hicimos
muchísimas entrevistas con trabajadores
temporales sobre todo de guatemala
es uno siempre está hablando por
supuesto de cómo viven acá cómo son
tratados por los patrones es que hay
diferencias entre un lugar y otro
hablamos de la explotación de la cual
son víctimas pero es cierto que es el
tema de las subjetividades y como estos
trabajadores viven acá y su separación
de la familia como les afecta en su
trabajo también cotidiano entonces eso
me parece que es una investigación muy
muy interesante bien pasamos ahora en
cara de las américas a leer vuestros
mensajes cartas hay alguna reacción en
las en facebook que no había alguien que
nos había dicho hace un rato que no
había audio y crochet y la audio está
ahí así que para mí es me garcía debe
ser un problema en su computadora un
programa un problema local y después
tenemos mucha gente que no se está
viendo pero que no ha participado
contexto yo tengo aquí un texto de jorge
herrera
tengo un texto de jorge herrera toledo
él dice importante la transmisión y muy
oportuna
gilberto martínez por su parte por su
parte dice saludos canadá en las
américas desde nicaragua y centroamérica
que también es una fuente también que
central es justamente un lugar donde
donde viene bastante emigración a
estados unidos y lo que justamente lo
que se olvida en historia es que fue la
causa de las migraciones fueron muchos
casos las políticas de eeuu en la región
grecia y que con la llegada de trump se
acelera también la llegada aquí claro
eso es otro fenómeno 60 destacando en la
actualidad si vamos a los mensajes yo
tengo aquí uno que nos manda a patricia
yancovich ella reacciona a la
información que nada ofrecerá una
entrada rápida inmigrantes calificados
en 50 ocupaciones y le hace una
observación muy interesante ya dice por
favor quien hace la traducción al
español variado de 24 países
greg en el género femenino al mencionar
las profesiones en título porque
existimos el género femenino en
profesión académica y lo más importante
y menos pagada y por nosotras nace el
género masculino la gramática es muy
importante porque se lee y se graba la
memoria y no debemos de una vez por
todas aprender el estilo masculino en la
pronunciación ya que nos descartan y no
podemos asumir que estamos involucradas
más gracias y estoy informando me
siempre con ustedes todo mi respeto dice
patricia janko beats a propósito del uso
de los géneros en el español es que es
una es difícil salir de un debate viejo
debate que anda en francia tuvo pues su
apogeo me acuerdo y hay lenguas no como
él como el persa justamente en que no
hay género
tampoco hay género lo cual facilita
mucho la cosa para nosotros en español y
en francés
y finalmente pues el género está ahí y
bueno en las publicaciones académicas ya
que estábamos hablando con la profesora
leona en las publicaciones académicas de
entrada se dice que se utiliza el que el
masculino para no alargar el texto
porque si no tenemos que decir los
trabajadores y las trabajadoras los y
las los y las entonces imagínate
hablar siempre teniendo en cuenta ese
elemento pues se complica de alguna
forma la comunicación aunque podría ser
al revés ponerse todo en femenino decir
que el femenino
implica también masculino cosa que no se
hace visto un solo profesor hacer esa
universidad pero sí creo que vale la
pena sexpe porque no seguimos rigiendo
digamos por la regla de la real academia
de la lengua española y que es que el
masculino se impone sobre el femenino
pero puede cambiar claro está puede
cambiar solo que se puede prestar para
malos entendidos de alguna forma
bueno digamos lo que pasa que somos
animal de costumbre
mal acostumbrado
más crece lópez obrador en sondeos una
entrevista con john ackerman si esta
moda
escribió ricardo y ricardo dice el
doctor ackermann preocupadísimo por los
derechos de los mineros en méxico la
semana pasada defendiendo al exiliado el
exiliado líder minero napoleón gómez que
vive en vancouver desde hace 13 años por
un fraude a las cuentas de los mineros
supongo no se entera que para el
pobrecito de napoleón que desapareció
millones de dólares dice ricardo los
mineros de su sindicato en méxico
aportan parte de su salario para su
defensa jurídica y la dura vida que
lleva en vancouver donde vive en un
apartamento y donde sus hijos tienen
de negocios pero que dura vida llevando
a los pobres bueno entonces a mí me
parece que ricardo está un poquito
enojado con lópez obrador y con napoleón
porque dice por eso lópez obrador le
está regalando un puesto en el senado
entonces esta es la opinión de ricardo y
así puedo díaz y escribe juan manuel y
dice en respuesta a wilfredo montilla
que no sé lo que dice wilfredo dice aquí
estamos así estamos ya aquí amigo y no
precisamente con él lópez obrador
bendiciones para ti entonces no sé a
quién le contestaban por éstas de una de
respuestas
continuando con
las elecciones en méxico jose carlos
josé martínez dicen dice los que se
saben perdidos y entre paréntesis
escribe la mafia del poder no saben
perder y quieren otra vez robarse la
elección presidencial pero el soberano
pueblo de méxico ya despertó entre
paréntesis como un tigre y no nos vamos
a dejar robar otra vez computadoras un
comentario de jose carlos ponce martínez
desde mexico me imagina aquí tengo un
mensaje que nos envía javier gonzález
nunca hará el presente desde guadalajara
jalisco mexico muchos saludos como cada
semana saludos a ver para ti entonces
avergonzar con garay y tenemos un
pequeño mensaje sobre el nuevo libro
documental la presencia chilena en
quebec que osvaldo núñez ya tu y que él
me dice excelente libro sobre la llegada
a la evolución y el accionar de los
miles de chilenos que viven en quebec
provincia franz ciencia de canadá de más
de 8 millones de habitantes mi amigo
sergio martínez escribe
y me menciona como el primer diputado de
origen latinoamericano en canadá cargo
que ejerce en la cámara de los comunes
desde el 93 el 97 y no hasta el 96 como
lo indica así que para corregir un
pequeño error en cuanto a las fechas de
esta participación están escuchando una
de las américas café en las zonas de
radio canadá aunque no había más que
ondas son señales digitales pasamos
ahora los temas de la semana leonora tú
has estado justamente explorando esto de
que puede significar el perder la
memoria y no darse cuenta es muy serio
es muy serio el tema y preocupante para
aquellos que sienten que están perdiendo
la memoria pero cuidado los que se dan
cuenta que están perdiendo la memoria
parece que están a salvo eso es un poco
la hipótesis que manejan en la casa
blanca la memoria que los médicos que
trabajan con
personas con riesgo de desarrollar
demencia ya sospechan desde hace
muchísimo tiempo que los pacientes que
no se dan cuenta de que experimentan
cierta pérdida de memoria corren un
mayor riesgo de empeorar entonces con
esa memoria y lo que hicieron estos
expertos en neurólogos en la universidad
mcgill es que finalmente esa hipótesis
con demostrar la eso es lo más
interesante del tema hice una entrevista
con el doctor pedro rosa neto es el que
dirige el laboratorio de neuroimagen
traslacional aparte se trabaja en el
instituto neurológico de montreal
etcétera etcétera él es de origen
brasileño y entonces se lo que él dice
es que es bueno el estado de demencia
dice él es cuando el paciente presenta
problemas cognitivos como pérdida de
memoria dificultades en expresarse
verbalmente y asociado a una disminución
a una pérdida de autonomía y lo que él
define el equipo de la demás definen
como la de la demencia la definen dice
proceso un proceso que comprende tres
estadios el primer estadio es el pre
clínico donde hay depósitos de proteínas
en el cerebro pero todavía no hay
síntomas el segundo estadio se
caracteriza por síntomas leves y el
tercero ya es la demencia y lo que ellos
hicieron en su investigación es es
investigar a pepe el segundo estadio
leve pérdida no de síntomas leves de
problemas de memoria y bueno la muestra
fue de casi 600 personas de mayores de
65 años con estas características y
bueno voy a resumir por qué no hay mucho
tiempo simplemente le pregunté cuáles
eran buenos los resultados concretos de
esta investigación y él dijo de los casi
500 pacientes analizados con problemas
cognitivos leves
pensamos que cerca de un 50 por ciento
va a desarrollar la demencia en cinco
años y menos es decir el 50 por ciento
la mitad que presentaban las que
presentaban leves síntomas de pérdida de
memoria un 40 por ciento va a llevar una
vida normal
y un 10% puede mejorar su memoria y
entonces ese es el es decir hay
medicamentos que están investigando y
que pueden ayudar a retrasar oa
modificar incluso esa pérdida que puede
ser grave de memoria entonces ahí hay
indicios hay otras cosas por supuesto
que está en este
en esta entrevista con el doctor pero es
alimentos ejercicios o son solamente
medicamentos hay medicamentos pero
también hay un estilo de vida que ayuda
entonces es interesante también por eso
pero bueno es lo novedoso para mí es
esto de que lo que ellos dicen se dan
cuenta es fundamental cuando ellos van
ao cuando una persona va a ver va a ver
a un neurólogo a un médico por problemas
ciertos problemas de memoria de pérdida
es súper importante ir con un miembro de
la familia porque son los miembros de la
familia los que se dan cuenta del
problema y a veces la persona no se da
cuenta y ahí es cuando se hacen
entrevistas con miembro de familia y con
la persona donde ellos pueden detectar
el problema entonces ayuda muchísimo
muchísimo
lo que pasa con secreto profesional en
relación no hay secreto acá es decir si
os quieres porque además eso le ayuda a
la familia
hay una detección rápida ayuda a la
familia y a la persona concernida se
dice concernida si a tomar las medidas
que hacen falta y además hay que pensar
y por ejemplo lo que ellos dicen no es
cuando ya no estás aquí allá de con la
posibilidad de hacerte cargo de tu vida
financiera hay que prever todo eso
entonces yo creo que en la persona que
sea que va a tener problemas de pérdida
de memoria creo que va a querer que se
sepa y que la familia sepa para poder
llevar exactamente con tenerla esa de
hecho ha habido abusos de personas
mayores que pierden la memoria y en
términos financieros dictámen las
personas que controlan las cuentas y
todo lo demás
es cierto entonces ese me pareció pues
se interesante el doctor
rosa neto el reportaje está en nuestro
sitio internet eres en el punto sea
pablo tú nos presentas a roberto fonseca
si roberto fonseca que es un gran músico
cubano es uno de los mejores músicos de
la nueva guardia por llamarlo así ya no
es la trova es la nueva trova
este es un músico joven pianista él
viene de una familia hijos su padre
roberto fonseca señor era era pianista
también no era baterista su madre una
cantante profesional de sangre de hecho
en uno de sus árboles de esos discos que
se llama samba su que roberto fonseca
grabó en el 2007 su madre canta con él
yo le preguntaba en un momento en la
entrevista roberto si este momento lo
había marcado
en su historia como músico y ese
justamente era un momento recuerda con
mucha afección y es cuando estuvo
tocando el piano y que su madre cantó
con él bueno él no canta el extenista es
un gran pianista entonces pues y porque
hablamos de roberto fonseca porque se va
a presentar aquí en canadá este fin de
semana el domingo en vancouver y va a
presentar un espectáculo allí él lo que
propulsó la carrera o roberto fonseca
empezó a estudiar música desde los 4
años desde muy chiquititos adaptar lo
más lejos que recuerda en su memoria
siempre la música ha estado en sus manos
con padres músicos tiene dos medios
hermanos que son músicos también uno es
emilio valdés que es baterista y otro
pianista jesús chiquito valdez chiquito
porque es hijo de chucho valdés el con
quien la madre de roberto tuvo dos niños
en un matrimonio anterior entonces es
todo música por todos lados
y bueno lo otro momento también muy
clave en la carrera musical de roberto
fonseca aparte de haber tocado y copar
para su mamá y que ella cantará fue
cuando entró en el buenavista social
club
el buenavista social club fue el que le
dio el empujón que lo lanzó digamos a la
conquista del mundo y que sucedió que lo
habían llamado para que fuera suplente
de el pianista de buenavista social club
que como ustedes a cualquiera rubén
gonzález el gran rubén gonzález entonces
yo le preguntaba justamente cómo fue
meterse en los zapatos de rubén gonzález
porque bueno es
un gran músico cubano entonces me decía
que bueno pues siempre pues al principio
él encontró un poco duro pero ya ves
preferencia en do ese temor y fue así
como participó en la gira de adiós de
ibrahim ferrer
entonces en la entrevista con roberto
fonseca hablamos de eso un poco más así
que he escuchado a pablo y mi
pensamiento se iba hacia esta tendencia
que uno tiene a decir en una familia de
médicos salen médico los hijos que
aburridos no abogados pero cuando se
trata de músicos qué maravilla porque
administraciones tuvieron hijos de
músicos
dos veces y los hijos de los dos de la
administración
porque decir que es aburrido es los que
son médicos hijos de médicos tíos de
médicos te acuerdas que en las teorías
de comunicación que estudiamos hace ya
muchos años decían justamente eso que
hay estudios que se habían hecho que
demostraban que los hijos de los
profesionales y van a seleccionar a
influir en carrera
como lo estamos viendo con los músicos
aquí tengo dos mensajes antes de seguir
muchos saludos a don daniel camporini y
sus historias de la radio que se hizo
presente y javier el negro rosas vice
leo pagar lo que debes en san luís
abrazo se ríe
[Música]
aprendieron a la vuelta de las aguas
cuando no cuando deje de nevar parece
que el país porque para los que no saben
mañana y pasado se anuncia nieve 20
centímetros es el de realmente el
regreso del jedi
volvemos ahora los últimos el último par
de minutos en el programa leonardo
rápidamente perfiles sombra con esto de
cambridge analítica y todo lo que pasó
con facebook se descubrió esto de los
perfiles sombras que tiene que
es muy interesante porque la gente que
dice no no yo no voy a tener nunca una
cuenta de facebook es probable que ya
estén en la base de datos de facebook
gracias a estos perfiles sombras que lo
que hacen básicamente es yo instaló la
aplicación de facebook en mi teléfono
escanea mis datos entre ellos todos mis
contactos y los guarda en una base de
datos y yo tengo por ejemplo un contacto
lo tengo a pablo y tengo los cuatro
teléfonos de él el celular en el trabajo
en su casa de campo
tienen todo dirección todo lo que yo
tenga en mi teléfono de él lo tienen
porque yo tuve o tengo una cuenta de
facebook posible que una persona que no
está en facebook
igual facebook tengan los datos es
simplemente eso pero que pues estas seis
book y yo me ven como amigo a pablo no
no no pero supongamos que él no tiene
cuenta en facebook pero yo lo tengo mis
contactos del teléfono para llamarlo por
teléfono guarda todos estos datos que es
un pulpo que se apodera de todos los
datos en un tercio uno de los de las
personas que estaba
en la comparecencia de zuckerberg dijo
que es probable si esto pasa con un
teléfono es probable que un casi un 100
por ciento de las páginas de internet
hoy en día tienen el logo de facebook
estarán espiándonos por ahí está el tema
nuevamente antes de no sé que nada
expulsa diplomáticos rusos por haber
dicho la verdad y justamente entonces
esta histeria que y realmente estamos
alguien comparó este momento con casi
con algunos elementos de la crisis de
octubre del 62 en que hay la posibilidad
por lo menos teórica de una enfrenta con
una confrontación militar entre eeuu y
rusia y canadá se sumó al baile
expulsando a cuatro diplomáticos rusos y
la razón que dio el gobierno ya ciento
dijo que estaba atrás estaba estaban
hablando mal o estaban dando mala fama a
la ministra de relaciones exteriores
sister freeman que finalmente todo lo
que ven todos los rusos será decir que
su abuelo había sido colaborador nazi
primero en ucrania se refugió en polonia
y con bajo la protección de los nazis
publicaba periódicos antisemitas
esto es nada más que en la punta del
aire porque hay nada hay una estamos un
momento muy complejo en el que
lastimosamente si no lees las noticias
de los medios de comunicación tres
países se sientan a planificar un ataque
y sabe todas las potencias occidentales
es decir y no hay hasta el momento el
organismo que tiene que decir si hubo un
ataque con armas químicas y no todavía
no hay no hay un informe final y es
lamentable que tres países tomen la
decisión por todo el mundo porque todo
el mundo
ataque con ira con las armas de ese
lobby y aquí les dejamos los espías nos
perdimos
nos fuimos nos vemos la próxima semana
estaremos de regreso en siete días adiós